how's it going citizens of the reject
Nation John here for another movie
reaction to a film I am very excited to
check out obviously missed it back when
it first came out people have been
recommending it to me ever since and
that is 2005's Sky High starring Kurt
Russell and Michael angarano who went to
my high school but I I barely ever saw
for obvious reasons yeah guys if you
could go ahead and leave a like on this
video that would be very much
appreciated also leave a comment below
let me know what other movies would like
to see to see me check out that maybe I
haven't already seen and uh go ahead
also and hit that subscribe button and
the notification Bell so you can stay up
to date with everything we got going on
here at the channel and if you would
like to sync up with me and get the full
Sky High experience come on over to our
patreon page patreon.com real rejects
you will sync up with your own copy but
if you want to see all the stuff that
doesn't make it to the reaction that's
the place to do that and we got reaction
highlights and watch alongs for various
other shows and films as well it's a
great time really really really
appreciate all our super sexy rejects
over there you can also support the
channel by checking out our merch store
at shopzeroedition.com grab yourself a
t-shirt hat or a hoodie very much
appreciated to everyone who's rocking
the real reject swag and last but
certainly not least thank you to the
folks over at prepper for editing down
these highlights it is a big old task
and we very much appreciate them for
helping us out with that and uh yeah
without further ado
let's get super let's is this guy hi
yeah
[Music]
in a world full of superheroes there are
two that stand Above the Rest the
commander and jet stream
okay
Stephen Josie stronghold the top real
estate agents in the Metropolis of
Knoxville nice
me I have my own names for them mom and
daddy okay
I just have one small problem
it's okay there are other things to be
super at you don't have to be super
strong necessarily
oh oh
[Laughter]
nah you can't lie you can't pull a fast
one on your dad you can't pull a fast
run on the commander it's nice to know
that whatever happens to me
you'll still be around to save the world
looking forward to it we are oh boy oh
nice oh damn what the
see
thank you mayor there's trouble downtown
big trouble big trouble
in Little China
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
that's a lovely power
[Music]
I like their teamwork oh thanks
you know for when this was made that
doesn't look too bad what's your name
freshman uh Will Stronghold
the son of the Commander in jet stream
oh my your third generation man magenta
get up
why so he can sit with his girlfriend
Layla no she's just my friend
oh no
morning
oh
[Music]
I do love how gleeful this movie is in
its application of comic book Aesthetics
like I feel like we're a bit too cool
for this now
but uh I'm loving this so far
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll do a flyby with Miss Frizzle at
some point
there she is
Sky High
it's literal you ever running late are
you running early or you just want to
talk
give me a call thanks Ron I'm gonna find
me one of those on eBay
[Music]
I
uh okay I mean they had that coming
[Music]
speed around about okay
whoa
oh this is so fun
attention please
we'd be happy to collect that 15 new
student fee okay guys very funny I'll
take over from here Mary Elizabeth
Winstead
Ramona Flowers good morning I am
principal Powers Linda Carter you will
go through Power placement and your own
heroic Journey will begin all the hero
Jack the loser track okay there's a
loser track I believe the preferred term
is hero support oh wow show me your
power yes she will do so in front of the
entire class I will then determine where
you will be assigned hero or sidekick oh
dang
all right I'm glowing I don't think so
maybe we can turn off these lights we
could cup your hands around your eyes
no I promise I will not call that
character Aaron Carter this whole time
but he just looks so much like Aaron
Carter right away sir
whoa that's pretty impressive
for a popsicle sidekick
that was my man spider just then
[Music]
[Applause]
a handsome one at that
get out of here knucklehead
what a guinea pig yep not even a swarm
of guinea pigs uh no anamorph I think
the whole hero sidekick dichotomy only
serves you let me get this straight are
you refusing to show me your powers it's
more complicated than that I mean
ouch
dude my it's War and Peace I've heard
about him his mom's a hero and his dad's
a super villain so where am I coming
your dad busted his dad quadruple life
sentence no chance of parole until after
his third life Wow
[Music]
can't be enemies forever
what do you mean you don't know what
your power is no no
got it you're messing with the coach
just like your old man car whoa
I don't have super strength
you're a flyer just like your mom why
don't you say so
oh
this was coming Pete
there are cases rare where the child of
two super powered parents
never
pliers
any
Powers oh
like who well I know of only one Ron
Wilson Bus Driver Ron Wilson Dad we need
to talk I mean little hero to Hero talk
oh God you must never ever bring anyone
into the secret sanctimots why it's
called the secret
especially not Gwen Grayson don't bring
her
got a pool table how about the pinball
machine
I want a pinball machine and a pool
table this is the best gadgetry what not
this is the greatest
and is this uh Royal Pains pacifier
[Music]
I wish you could have seen us we were
fantastic royal pain got his and I got
the pacifier
it's amazing
what'd you do no idea
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're all right
hey he's got the eagle the size of a
giant robot
the Little Men In Black in here too
everybody expects greatness for me well
you are great
when life gives you money
make apple juice can't make lemons I
don't know what
huh you will make lemons
is
oh All-American boy all right I was
paired with
the commander I didn't know you worked
for the commander I worked with the
commander
[Music]
Steve's son
yeah and you never he never mentioned me
to you I don't I don't think so
ouch incoming what
crisis situation what is it he does glow
hey
I told you
cool oh damn huh little misfire in the
mad science lab
no need to panic
unless you're a single cell organism
oh
crowd that is
salt lamps they're like the Infinity
Stones
you got the Quick Change
oh
classic Disney underwear joke what's
your name what's your power I'm Ethan I
built okay Zach I glow I see I see is
that that one kid really you know glow
sometimes actually they're all sidekicks
oh
oh good for you son
your stature hanging out with a bunch of
Sidekicks as a freshman I didn't have
the guts and I can only imagine what
your grandfather would have said that I
brought some of them home oh my
god dad um a sidekick okay
I washed out of power placement
oh it's not Coach Boomer it's me okay I
don't have any powers
the fact of the matter is
I'm proud to be a sidekick
I'm proud to be hero support oh
to guts man
to courage
so many great little gags
I think I didn't want to see my son fly
I have super strength or fly butterfly
but we can't change who he is not
without dropping him in a vat of toxic
waste
that's it but we will be the stronghold
3 the greatest family the world has ever
known
you're right and he can always go into
real estate
that's right you can make quite a living
he can be your support you know
whoa
ouch
oh let's do this
all right let's not do this you think
you can do whatever you want just
because your name's stronghold I'm sorry
that my dad put your dad in jail but
whoa
[Music]
I'm Ghost Rider
whoa nice
[Music]
leave them alone hey
the power kicks in we're strong super
strong oh
wow
he is super strong jeez
nice
[Music]
uh oh
it's time for the lasso of Truth the
detention room neutralizes all
superpowers
sit damn whatever happened with our dads
it has nothing to do with us
if you ever cross me again I'll roast
you alive
whoa
so will
anything interesting happen at school
today you nearly destroyed the cafeteria
yeah Mom I got my powers and do you know
how to use them wisely
sanctum oh
William Theodore stronghold
he's Bill and Ted come here
boy has super strength how can I be mad
sorry
you are strong I can I could do with the
back crack I took away your Xbox
but I don't have an Xbox are you sure
oh my God
evil
waited this long when the time is right
we'll have our revenge you know time
would move a lot faster we had an expert
oh
uh would you gather your gear and come
up here please I've got your new
class schedule
oh you're going through the hero class
now
hero class what about them we'll still
see you on the bus yeah we'll hang a
lunch right after you finish dunking
Ethan's head in the toilet
unfortunately all the Lab Partners are
taken
I suppose I could pair you with my
teaching assistant oh goodness
come on
okay I have no idea what I'm doing
well technique give confused Rays with
beams oh so totally different things
that would only mean
what have we here
do it you're far too modest Mr
stronghold
dang I can control technology with my
mind you know I can totally help you out
with all this science stuff
um
I'm good at chemistry as well will City
one Grayson my name's Hyde Gotta Give
him that
oh
maybe tonight we can go to the paper
lantern
Chinese food
paper lantern in
oh it will beat you and save the citizen
you lay off a Sidekicks for the rest of
the year yeah and if he loses you can
dunk Ethan said in the toilet every day
till graduation yeah oh no Ethan
no
uh remember we used to use real citizens
of course you did stronghold you're the
hero
hey get your head in the game yeah
midoriya listen to bakugo
[Applause]
surprised me of like rollerball a little
bit
see Aesthetics of this bit
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I love that there's a pay phone
it's just a couple little things a
mailbox
[Music]
remember what this is really about
[Music]
oh suffocation
save your friend to be
whoa oh my
dang
nice
Gwen here's a technopath and she's
offered to help will with his science
homework and she's a senior
she could get into the sanctum or
destroy the eye I don't know
oh
oh no
that's right damn oh
that wouldn't act
lets mom do all the work now huh
actually mom passed away when I was a
baby
I was wondering if you two would
consider attending the homecoming dance
we were hoping that you'd be the guest
of honor and receive the award for
Heroes of the year
oh I'm so nervous I feel like
something's up
still working on that
oh we go to school together
you're a strongholds right yeah
for for how much longer remember her huh
she was a weird one oh yes
disappeared right before graduation
that's her mom well will could not
figure out why mine was growing so
quickly it was driving him crazy so
finally I took Mercy on him and I told
him about my powers
best friends ever since and falling for
almost that before or after the lima
beans oh
I'm not in love with Wills yes you are
you like somebody else and
she's perfect
to let True Love Remain unspoken
this is the quickest route to heavy
heart damn
#deep and your lucky numbers are
16 5 and 49. smooth I'm so glad they're
coming to homecoming
I don't know if I could only find
someone to go with no no no I don't
trust her I'm just waiting for the right
guy
you
[ __ ] me
oh hi Daddy
Jim Rash
[Music]
whoa
oh you got both sets of powers
and interestingly timed the way they
both emerge
him surfboard I want this joystick
all right right the pacifier hey
[Music]
oh I totally spaced
I'm sorry I I know you must want to kill
me actually just the opposite
I tell you
oh it's about homecoming really
really me too I'm going with Gwen
Grayson can you believe it
oh man I feel so bad for her
she's the way she plays that like
sweet
yeah question oh who asked me War and
Peace how could you go with him when did
you even start hanging out last night
eight o'clock the paper lantern
so you're not doing this just because
you like me or anything you're gonna see
in the stronghold
but I'm not ready at Ducks
interesting two days to your mad science
midterm and I am not gonna rest until
you can build a ray gun blindfolded oh
my God I think that's
this is my College library and Michael
angarano went to my high school but I
never saw him because he's probably
shooting this
do you think the committee gets stopped
by
my parents are on a distressed call and
they won't be home till late and I'm
really not supposed to have anyone here
it's cool I was just hoping we could
oh
no
if it's only a few people
super golly
Glenn you said this was supposed to be
homecoming committee this is the
homecoming committee okay okay so a few
extra people showed up it's the entire
homecoming my friends what about them
they're all here
oh
I mean your nerd friends
no I think they'd be okay trust me
they'd be miserable oh I wish there was
somewhere we could go to
be alone no
no no no no no no no no no
don't do it
this is incredible
yep though when you spend your whole
life kicking butt and taking names out
because you make a lot of memories
maybe we should make fever oh
yep
where's will honestly avoiding you
ouch
will knows you have a crush on him he
dies well it's just a nice guy to tell
you he's not interested not that you can
take a hint
he's going to homecoming with me he
threw a party and didn't invite you
you're just embarrassing him you're just
embarrassing yourself
okay I understand
true evil plan
when you see will again can you tell him
that I never want to talk to him again
I'll give him a message
Layla Layla
Layla
have fun with Gwen you two deserve each
other
[Music]
what did you say to Layla nothing and I
just told her the truth yeah not going
anywhere with you not now or not to
homecoming
might as well just find yourself a new
day coin wow
let's get something straight okay you do
sorry Gwen I uh just did wow
party's over don't stop on our account
I've got half of mine not to let him go
to homecoming it's fun I'm not going
anyway whoa whoa whoa whoa your mom said
she had half a mind
did something happen well I don't want
to talk about it
D well we're gonna talk about it because
we promised Gwen we'd go to the dance
oh no
okay let's just pick up
okay in case you didn't get my earlier
messages I'm at the paper lantern and I
dude you don't have to worry about me
ruining your night and why is that
because I'm not going hmm
well that sucks
because we're only going together to
make you jealous
oh dude you're so stupid she's totally
into you
let's have a bro talk
I'm gonna be surprised if Layla or any
of the other guys ever want to talk to
me again
it must have been a real jerk
come on you two do the do the you know
the Bro Shake where you do the whole
forearm come on
do that I hate you but damn it I respect
you and Jake
hey you want to dance no me neither
that was funny
thanks a lot
he got the suit
it's my dad's it was that much use for
it in solitary
put this away from me I caught your
father trying to sneak it out under his
cape he's convinced that everyone at
homecoming wants to reminisce with him
will do love you have fun I like how the
commanders like Jack Burton and Steve is
is like uh his name Henry Swanson he
looks just like Henry Swanson or
whatever the dweeb character he plays in
uh big trouble is Henry Swanson's my
name and excitement's my game
that's weird
yeah I knew it no I knew it the pacifier
it's great lighting queue too for that
[Music]
one
I love that that came back that's
awesome
powerful super
ever to walk the halls of Sky High
me yes you knew this was coming Pete
I'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
oh
[Music]
dang this is still eating do you
honestly think you can kill me with that
little toy gun of yours my dear
commander who said anything about
killing you oh
gotta watch what you say
oh
I knew it had to be some of the baby
related that's yes these are damn it
oh diabolical
no baby mama
hey damn
now you've saved each of their lives
[Music]
oh he didn't have a giant baby brain
[Music]
the ones who can copy themselves they
feel like are often nefarious no wrong
if I'm not back in 30 minutes coming
after you got
I was gonna say go get help
go get help got it now get in there
coming after you
what's up kid
I'm gonna do like a joker bus Heist
the rest of us are only Sidekicks just
because you have powers that doesn't
make you a hero
sometimes it just makes you a jerk
makes me a jerk
I guess what I'm trying to say is we get
it you've been a jerk
Layla
in case my homecoming date ends up
killing me tonight oh I just want you to
know oh
you guys are a part of this too why am I
not surprised go take care of Gwen
clowns
yeah buddy
[Music]
that's awesome
now you just calmed down let's go back
to one
it's a very great like comic bookie kind
of plan to turning everyone into babies
aren't you gonna fight back I don't
believe in using my powers for violence
I don't believe you even have any power
come on Miyagi doe this self-defense
no way
oh
this is a little disturbing whoa
baby gondola ride
a time before anyone knew
[Music]
she has to plan to start her very own
super villain Academy
oh
when the pacifier exploded I wasn't
destroyed I was merely turned into a
baby
that's cool
raised me as his daughter that is little
girl
oh you never told me that is that also
Jim Rash in there it's like it's alien
form
the pain wasn't my mother
royal pain
thanks
now it's Man of Steel
[Music]
oh
right into the flying
uh relief sculpture mural thing
[Music]
the balloons pop in this fun
it's a pretty Punchy action scenes in
this movie
throwing down
big mistake
[Music]
oh let's go poison ivy
poison ivy with a little bit of storm
Vibe
[Applause]
um
Royal Pains sabotaging anti-gravity to
fight the whole school's gonna fall out
of the sky we only have 10 minutes I
mean you should have thought of that
gravity room but didn't Royal paint seal
off every route hey what about this
conduit yeah right you'd have to be like
a rat to fit in there
it is your time purple girl
okay go about 10 feet yeah there should
be opening on your right
behind the accident find the access
panel wow at least right to the
generator
[Music]
oh buddy
dang nice
[Music]
to the disco ball
[Music]
oh whoa
it's okay use that flight surprise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so am I
you can fly
[Music]
whoa
there's only one person authorized to
transport superheroes and that's Ron
Wilson Bus
Driver my man
[Music]
no
no
oh my God
I can almost feel the g-force
[Music]
come on buddy
come on
all unpacked and the movers didn't break
a thing I told you we didn't need that
extra insurance no I know SpongeBob what
are you doing here
[Applause]
save Tom Kenny and his lady friend who's
probably also some kind of voice actor
[Music]
oh
that could have been messy
[Music]
yeah buddy well done give me a couple of
hours so we can figure The Pacifier Mr
peace would you please carry me to the
mad science lab sure
and Mr peace yeah
incredibly I had made boom boom
uh
foreign
of course you have but you defeated her
you saved Sky High and everyone in her I
didn't do it by myself Steve
Josie hey this doesn't belong to us it's
a machine belongs to them Heroes
[Music]
whatever you're teaching them
teaching them
[Laughter]
[Music]
but a
hey
that's a nice little tie around
[Music]
classic prom song
I'll stop the world and Melt With You
should be Ah that's sweet
this should be what's his name Ethan's
theme song
but they are getting to spend a lot of
quality time together oh yeah and Ron
Wilson Bus Driver fell into a vat of
toxic waste hey that works for the mayor
defending the city from giant robots go
Ron Wilson my girlfriend became my Arch
Enemy my Arch Enemy became my best
friend and my best friend became my
girlfriend nice that's high school
happily ever after
oh that was really nice that was really
fun
and sweet
Will's strongholds good name now I
wonder if the block of CG animators is
as big as films are now oh Patrick
Warburton was the voice of royal pain
interesting great cast on this too
my friends this was such a fun
experience thank you again for joining
if you made it to this point in the
video thank you for being here because
this was really fun and really charming
and I I'm glad we got to share like even
though I'm here alone you know through
the transitory process of this
experience I'm glad we got to share it
because it is that kind of movie and it
is a fascinating one at least here in
the Afterglow to to look at and think
about in terms of of what like 17 years
ago when it came out versus here in 2022
the way this genre has grown and changed
and has you know
taken uh the ball you know from movies
like this and other adaptations at the
time of direct source material and just
sort of extrapolated on and evolved upon
that and and yeah it's like this movie
in a lot of ways feels a bit ahead of
its time all things considered uh
because I mean finding out at the
beginning or realizing you know
explicitly at the beginning that this
was a Disney production it did sort of
it Clues you into how and why some of
the tone and the humor is the way it is
but at the same time this felt like The
Best of Both Worlds between some kind of
Disney Channel original movie and
something they would put more faith in
and put in the movie in a theater you
know for their like you know Flagship
theatrical uh slate or whatever because
you know it's like there are aspects of
it that are very colorful and that do
feel
like sets but also like they're they're
really fun and imaginative and colorful
and the CG effects that they do
incorporate while you can tell that
they're there uh and while they haven't
aged like immaculately like they're
pretty good for what this is and and the
blend of all those elements all of those
physical and special effects uh you know
brings this together in a very charming
and very sort of comic book esque kind
of way and you do have you know the
framing devices uh at the beginning in
the end where they do the sort of comic
book panels and everything like that and
they sort of jump you in through that uh
you know scope through that um you know
through the scope of that medium and uh
I think it does really nicely to tread
that line because in a lot of ways this
is shot like I love when uh that scene
early on in the movie where um you know
Steve and Josie are at the table with
Will and they get the call on the red
phone and then all of a sudden it's like
touch angles and all crazy shots and uh
and yeah like this had a a sense of
cheekiness from behind the camera that I
think at some point during the reaction
I said like I feel like we're getting
too cool for this kind of thing and uh
and I'm not uh I don't disagree with my
past self when I said that because uh oh
that sounds so pretentious yeah I feel
like we have gotten a bit too cool for
some of the aspects that I think are so
great about this movie that I maybe wish
could come back in a certain way shape
or form I mean you know I guess you
could argue that what Sony does with
their movies uh has
a certain amount of innate cheekiness
about it or innate sense of fun maybe
but now that's not even the same as what
I'm getting at here like this is I I
think it's the perfect flavor and it's
uh you know the perfect thing to sort of
reach across you know I feel like young
people can watch this you know uh
anybody who's an adult comic book nerd
can easily watch this and and two I mean
it has a pretty classic story so anybody
who's probably a fan of The Breakfast
Club or something like that can also get
into this and uh yeah it manages to be
such that you know if you're watching it
at my age you're not like well you know
like what is this you know kid stuff uh
you know like it is in ways but I think
it's handled in such a way that is just
a bit more nuanced than I would have
expected I mean like I said part of it
is classic but I like that sort of the
core struggle is yeah you've got this
kid who you know is sort of trying to
live up to his parents expectations and
to their legacy and he's you know know
trying to find where he fits and you
know you're going to high school for the
first time like that's a super relatable
thing you know you're feeling alienated
and you're you know quickly falling into
the sort of reject bin for you know
there's various reasons beyond your
control and uh and having that play into
a sort of internal struggle later on I
thought was a really nice thing because
obviously the popularity and the
attention that Will Stronghold receives
it's like it changes over time because
you know it starts out with him finding
his people among you know the sidekicks
and the support teams and you know the
people who have like Oddball you know
not quite obviously super heroic powers
and then yeah as he gets more and more
attention from Gwen who Who hats off
like Mary Elizabeth Winstead is like on
another level in this movie of like
magical intoxicating just loveliness for
so much of it to the point like I love
that that is kind of what makes it seem
so suspicious this is so so perfect and
she comes with this music all the time
and you know you start to see through
her behavior that yeah at least at
minimum she's kind of a petty popular
girl but at most maybe she is much more
and I thought you know even though it's
not like wildly unpredictable I thought
the way they laced in the clues with her
and just the way that they used the
tapestry of high school scenarios to
illustrate her intents and the intents
of everyone around you know you have I
think a really fun story in that you
know where yeah he does let it go to his
head and he does get his powers so then
he does it's like yeah what happens when
a guy who you know hasn't been handed
all that he thinks uh and the world
seems to think he should have been
handed you know how does that guy cope
with that and then what happens when all
of a sudden you get everything you
always wanted and thought you couldn't
have and yeah I mean I thought Michael
and garano at the center of this did a
nice job of of playing that balance um
and and especially too I mean I think
Disney movies
maybe less so now than before but you
know there is a certain kind of acting
style that comes with these things but I
thought he towed the line nicely where
he was Charming
um but you know still appropriate for
again like I mean this in the least
negative way possible like aspects of
this do feel like it could have been a
Disney Channel Original Series or
something like that that um you know if
you divide this up and maybe made
certain scenarios a full episode or
whatever this could be you know a series
in some of the way it's presented but uh
but yeah him and and the entire ensemble
of Sidekicks and and Oddball characters
like even though there is some of that
quintessential Disney humor I thought
they were all pretty Charming as this
sort of yeah ragtag bunch of Misfits and
the way in which all their powers come
together at the end to save the day you
know even though it's something you can
certainly see coming it still comes
across like it's still executed well
enough that you are you know uh thrilled
for them and you do feel that catharsis
for them by the end like it is still
triumphant most triumphant and I feel
like that's like you can do a bunch of
classic things that we can all see
coming and I think just the the main
factor in distinguishing between you
know whether that's rote and lazy versus
whether it's fun and clever it's just
yeah how well the execution goes across
and I feel like across this all the
actors showed up and two I mean it's
been fun to Just note like how much both
just uh acting in general cred uh some
of this like this is a huge cast and
it's only gotten bigger as time has gone
on it would seem because you have all
these Heavies like Kurt Russell and
Kelly Preston who I thought were really
great together as uh as uh Steve and
Josie and you know seeing them in both
of those modes like obviously especially
with Kurt Russell they're playing off of
you know his Persona and certain of his
character they make a big trouble
reference uh you know there's a lot of
Jack Burton in there
um but yeah you know they are are so
they're obviously big name draws for the
adults as are people like Linda Carter
and Cloris Leachman who are both great
in their roles Bruce Campbell Dave Foley
and Kevin McDonald like you got the uh I
mean Bruce Campbell just has genre cred
in general and Dave Foley and Kevin
McDonald obviously Kids in the Hall and
various other things so like yeah it's
it's got like a really great cast of
adult characters to you know help sell
the movie but also you know to see the
cred and just how how much this young
cast has grown I mean Michael angarano's
certainly done a lot of things uh Daniel
Panabaker uh certainly went on to do a
bunch and I mean she was in The Flash
and Mary Elizabeth Winstead has been
Huntress and has been in a bunch of
other like sci-fi and genre movies and
stuff like that and uh and friggin Zach
it's not a superhero thing but he's on
succession now like you know a lot of
these people have gone on uh you know to
either at least be working you know that
guys or you know people who have you
know pretty big careers now so it's just
it's always is a fun time capsule to see
that and and this movie uh gave me that
kind of throw but also just the thrill
of the Time Capsule of what it is in
general it's being a superhero movie a
superhero Pastiche a superhero tribute a
comic book movie very much so and uh
yeah it's like watching this now there's
certain stuff that it's like if you
didn't know when this came from you
would be like okay this is borrowing
from a whole bunch of things namely my
my hero Academia uh because yeah I mean
there's definitely stuff in here that
felt like my hero Academia I don't know
exactly when that manga started but I
feel like it may have been after this
and uh certainly the X-Men anytime you
have superhero youngsters in an academic
environment X-Men is going to be an
influence I mean this would have come
out at a time where you didn't have you
had a few Superhead adaptations Shores a
few comic book movies sure but certainly
not as many as we have now and so here
you have you know a lot of powers that
feel like X-Men powers and things like
that obviously uh the uh the commander
and jet stream feel like Superman and
Wonder Woman uh you know like there are
a lot of obvious nods which again I
don't begrudge the movie at all and I
feel like back at the time this came out
probably would have played as a lot more
just fresh you know because now we're so
used to seeing that and now we're in a
time where like superhero projects have
to distinguish each other because of the
amount of overlap that inevitably
happens when you just have these
galleries of heroes and villains with
different quirky Powers
um but yeah you know seeing the way it
has aged into and sort of foreshadowed a
lot of the genre to come uh was a really
fun thing and and yeah like looking at
stuff like my hero Academia and looking
at even you know like the current slate
of Marvel movies and stuff like that not
that those things are exactly like this
but you know like you can see where
certain DNA elements go and and come
from and where this may have at least
tread some ground uh before you know the
the wave we currently associate the
genre with most specifically but yeah
like this had a sense of of
um fun and abandon that I think we could
do with a little more of nowadays and I
mean like the the director of this movie
has done a lot of animated films and I
can actually absolutely see that as well
and I think that's maybe part of why the
some of the effects look as good as they
do given you know I can't imagine they
had all of the resources in the world at
the time and also too it was 2005
different set of tools at your disposal
um but yeah this definitely has the
energy and the the sort of spirit of an
animated movie and I feel like a lot of
at least some of our superhero movies
now could use a little bit of that
Spirit again uh because even though it
is cheeky and tongue-in-cheek and even
though there is a certain maybe element
of camp that comes along with it and I
mean I feel like you know if you got
often times not every time but
oftentimes if you have Bruce Campbell
somewhere in your movie there's probably
some kind of Camp element at its core
and uh I feel like superhero movies
could do with taking some of that uh
taking like a note from something like
this and bringing a little bit of that
back because it makes the behind the
camera presence feel just as alive as
the on-screen presences and those things
kind of lock together in a way that that
is sort of magical and fun and yeah like
this definitely has also too some Harry
Potter uh you know sort of similarities
and all that but I like the way the
story played out you know again I liked
uh having this kid's journey through
High School feeling like he's not living
up to his potential and to what he's you
know the role he's supposed to fill in
the world he's not going to be able to
complete his parents Trio this is the
perfect super family like it's a lot to
put on somebody and then yeah watching
as he slowly accepts his his station or
at least what he perceives to be a
station and you know it's like certain
aspects like that didn't play out the
way I expected it to with a certain
so look at how it's a decently healthy
family for as much as Kurt Russell's
character as for as much as Steve
stronghold is in denial about you know
the circumstances for his son you watch
him struggle with it but you ultimately
you see that he is a dad who loves his
kid and wants him to you know who wants
him to thrive and flourish even if he
does have to get used to the idea that
it's not exactly how he would have
imagined that happening
um but then seeing the reversal come
around like as he does get the powers
then he's like super jacked up and
excited I almost would have loved to
have seen like a bit more of that from
Kelly Preston just because he gets her
powers as well
um so you know ultimately it winds up
The Best of Both Worlds but you know
then it's like having the powers I like
that balance is you know at first he
doesn't have the powers but he makes you
know who will become his real and true
friends and and opening uh inadvertently
a door to you know making some kind of
peace with War and Peace which War and
Peace is a great superhero character
comic book name and a great you know
obvious uh but you know fun and punny
signifier for who this character is in
general and what his backstory is and
again like there are a lot of really
great comic book style backstories
throughout this like again someone who
clearly loved and grew up on Comics
conceived of and and people who love
Comics clearly were working on and
making this because there's just so much
it's like they threw everything and the
kitchen sink in there in terms of you
know tropes and archetypes and you know
nods to characters and powers and things
like that
um yeah like you can really tell that
they wanted to get the spirit of you
know a superhero comic book story right
but they also wanted to tell sort of an
endearing you know actual family story
and I like how crisp those things tie
together it's like yeah you have the
powers go to his head he alienates
himself from his friends
um you know he has these abilities
and he has you know the things he thinks
he wanted but really those are sort of
dragging him down and not making him
happy and it's making him sort of
neglect what's important in his life and
then on top of that you have you know
the the side door of the actual
conspiracy where you know Gwen is trying
to infiltrate the stronghold house to
get the pacifier back so that she can
reclaim her mantle as the royal pain and
I loved uh that the whole thing with the
royal pain like I thought the the drop
in the yearbook was good because you're
like okay clearly something's up with
her and clearly you've gotta you know
this has to have something to do with
you Mary Elizabeth Winstead but the
whole thing about yeah them vanquishing
the royal pain and the gun exploding and
reverting her back to a baby and she
gets this whole second chance and and
becomes the villain again you know uh I
thought that was a really fun and
interesting and and creative story I'm
I'm sure a comic book is done it
somewhere but yeah having them like all
transformed into babies I thought was
like a really sort of kooky and and
again very like this embraced the sides
of comics that are cool and the sides of
comics that are dorky and you know wild
and creative but also kind of silly but
in a way that's you know endearing and
and you know it's like yeah anything's
possible the imagination in a superhero
uh story can go just about anywhere so
yeah having it all sort of go down at
the school like I really like that segue
of okay she uh wants to have the party
at the house and that creates a scenario
in which they need to get some alone
time it alienates him from his friends
uh and then he'll take her down into the
sanctum she can swipe the gun and then
you know at the prom where they'll have
everyone together that they need uh then
they can you know exact their master
plan and uh yeah like I thought that the
way it spun both of those plates of just
this story of a kid trying to find his
way and stay true to himself in his
school and then also this big superhero
super villain plot was really nicely
handled and then too just introducing
all the lore of of Sky High itself as
this actual you know gravity-defying
high school and like all the stuff you
learn about that is you know part of the
climax directly they have to save the
school that seems like something that
you know is both nefarious for the
personal lives of our characters but
also um you know poses a big threat to
just the regular citizens down below and
even though you don't spend a lot of
time amongst the regular citizens like
having him you know stop the school from
falling on the house you know with Tom
Kenny uh SpongeBob himself among others
uh yeah like I thought they nicely
realized this world in a way that felt
like yeah they're just a lot of Heroes
everywhere but also you know like there
are regular people too and uh and
regular struggles aside from you know
the cool Fantastical superhero struggles
and so yeah I thought this was just like
really tight and fun and imaginative and
again all the cast showed up I mean you
know you can tell Mary Elizabeth
Winstead is like gonna go on and be a
friggin star and a half
um but everyone I thought did a nice job
to some degree I mean Danielle Panabaker
I thought was really endearing as Layla
and I mean her power I mean you know her
attitude is less of the you know gung-ho
superhero type but I love to what they
did with her her character kind of
poking at the Paradigm I feel like
that's sort of ahead of its time as well
uh you know for especially where the
conversation has gone uh in the current
day you know I I feel like the way she
wants to break away from the hero
sidekick Paradigm and just the way that
that affects people like why should you
know like you can see how it got that
way you can see how like okay yeah
certain powers lend themselves for
taking a lead and certain powers rep
lend themselves to support and also
heroes will always need gear and Gadget
like you get how the hero sidekick and
support uh Paradigm breaks down but at
the same time I liked that it seemed
like a genuine part of who that
character is especially as this uh
person with an earth-based power this
sort of uh you know healing and growth
based power uh until she's you know sat
at the paper lantern and Withers those
flowers uh but yeah like I liked the way
that ultimately the movie kind of
honored Honors that too and yeah it's
sort of
I don't know it presents sort of a more
Equitable way forward for the character
it's not like the point it's not like
this is a big message movie about you
know uh uh it's just intersectional
Equity among super-powered beings but
yeah I thought they committed to that in
a way that felt like it was authentic to
that character but also like the movie
wasn't just paying lip service to that
process you know and and and to the fact
that when you're especially in these
positions as a young person and you're
being sorted and put on these tracks
it's like yeah life isn't as crisp as
that and you're not always sure of where
you belong or you don't always have all
you need at the same time as everyone
else and so yeah like as fun and
imaginative as it is like with Coach
Boomer doing uh you know picking people
out in the gym and giving them these
different obstacles you know it's uh
it's again a perfectly relatable
scenario for anyone who's been to gym
class but also you know like a perfectly
Whimsical scenario for what's going on
but it's the same time you know I feel
like there is uh some lasting impact
from experiences like that that can be
reductive and that can you know cause
people angst and uh and difficulty and
so yeah having a character who's apt to
kind of break those barriers down and
and having it be then that the sidekicks
and and these characters with these
seemingly useless or or hard to apply
powers are the ones to save the day like
it's what it's gonna be but at the same
time I thought the movie bolstered that
outcome in a lot of different ways like
it sets up yeah each imaginative little
power but it also sets it up
thematically and two I mean everything
with War and Peace like I like the way
that that went down and the way that I
mean the interesting sort of uh effect
of having it be that his walls start
being broken down by Layla who is Will's
best friend who's yeah obviously in love
with him and who will doesn't you know
quite notice that way but through
through his uh her eyes you know he can
see what might be all right about this
guy and then you have the combined you
know sort of Greater threat at hand but
yeah having you know the Rivalry between
those two characters and the
misunderstandings that leads to among
the adults and and this rivalry that's
passed down that he didn't even have a
say in uh I like that and and two I mean
I I liked um Steven Strait's performance
as War and Peace I mean it does feel
very much sort of akin to like you know
your Casey Jones or or you know one of
those you know like a wrong side of the
tracks and I'm uh you know I'm a Loner
and I'm a bit of a you know I'm a bit
emo bit goth you know I'm I'm an
outsider don't look don't look me the
wrong way
um you know I like the way he played it
and I liked you know the the earnestness
again it's like it's the it's got the
right amount of height for what this is
but also the right amount of earnestness
to you know make it kind of a fun
triumphant moment most triumphant again
when yeah you do have them finally uh
kind of Ally them themselves at the end
and of course you know it's like and
then yeah I called out like Midori and
bakugou like of course they're gonna get
paired up for the uh save the civilian
thing and they're you know probably
going to Prevail but like even that like
I thought was really really well done
and uh just yeah like the the way this
movie handled both it just seemed like
everything it was trying to do it cared
equally about doing well and and keeping
within the spirit and fun of the story
so yeah like this was this was really
fun but also I thought really clever and
really nicely pitched and oriented and
uh and yeah great cast across the board
um like I said Cloris Leachman great
little appearances the nurse Bruce
Campbell loved him as uh as Coach Boomer
very much a Bruce Campbell character
Linda Carter uh Carter as principal
Powers I thought was nice in her
presence her commanding role there uh I
always love a Dave Foley appearance and
two I mean he
he's so great at playing just a complete
Sad Sack and I felt so bad for him
throughout just throughout the movie uh
you know for as willing and and you
could tell like back in the day he might
have been that peppy like that's right
Commander let's get him uh and yeah I
love that you know fill in the blank
holy blank blank man
um but yeah just like uh and and uh and
two um Kevin Heffernan we're on the bus
driver Ron Wilson Bus Driver like that's
another one of those like quirky comedy
characters that could easily fall flat
but again his just Plucky undying
enthusiasm was a nice thing and also
another sort of quintessentially comic
book flavor in my eyes and uh and uh
Kevin McDonald as well as as almost your
Professor Snape you know your sort of
requisite mad scientist Mr medulla uh
just yeah just like so many fun and
clever names and little ideas and again
powers and yeah all sorts of stuff that
is clear really derived from and paying
tribute to comic books and superhero
characters of all Stripes but also yeah
packaging it up in its own sort of
special world and I think especially in
a pre my hero Academia world that would
have probably felt a little more unique
than it does uh again if you don't have
that context in mind for 2022 but yeah I
feel like it's the best of a lot of
those worlds and yeah while it's not
necessarily like the most uh significant
reinvention of the wheel I feel like for
its time this is probably a a good
example of like a superhero movie done
well and even though it's not a direct
adaptation it feels like it is you know
it feels authentically like what it's
trying to be and the way that it
orchestrates its uh you know most
imaginative and action-packed scenes
with those different effects with the
Practical and physical effects and the
CG effects and all that stuff you know
like I love when they Vanquish the robot
and then they bring his giant eye home
like there there is just as much Whimsy
and and you know sort of fun and Camp as
there is you know teenage angst and all
those other things and a few notes of
like yeah why should it be so uh narrow
and binary this uh you know way that we
handle you know powers and and uh using
them for good for the good of the people
uh you know I just thought this was
really fun and clever and imaginative
and yeah
always always always always down for
some Kurt Russell action especially in a
role like this him and Kelly Preston I
thought were great together I'm glad
they finally got their family Trio and
yeah like really clever with uh Mary
Elizabeth Winstead and I thought you
know she played both of those roles uh
both before and after the the you know
he'll turn back to us uh really well and
uh again just uh such a lovely lovely
surprise and uh such a nice thing to get
to share so uh thank you guys if you
join me for joining me and uh yeah leave
me some comments and let me know what
else you'd like me to check out and uh I
will catch you for whatever comes next
uh yeah much love for now and as always
cheers
foreign
[Music]